a man I think tends to be among other
things more in tune with the harshest
aspects of reality he is uniquely called
to confront the darkness in the world
and uniquely equipped to for this
calling
you know a uniquely equipped to handle
all of this it's not that we don't feel
anything we do feel and we feel with
great depth but we carry those feelings
differently
and often we carry it in silence alone
this is how we're wired and the world
needs us to be wired this way
women are also oriented more towards
Community they build and depend upon
relationships men are more solitary by
Nature again these differences are
hardwired you know when we say that that
men shouldn't cry it's not just a joke
there's an important truth there